welcome to a day plus real talk josh to
a wrapped up as host of The Daily Show
this week his satirical take on the news
and politics will be missed by many
including our producer Kate you worked
on a piece of our Jon Stewart impact on
the media politics and the u.s. how
could a TV host comic become so it went
influential and powerful well obviously
he was funny oh he's really funny right
I mean in a time of a war awful
terrorist attack a president that was
not living up to our standards I feel
like a lot of people really connected
with what John was joking about but also
I think John would never say he was a
journalist right but he had the tools
and the the ability to say things that
traditional journalists couldn't say so
when it came to you know CNN anchors and
reporters have to have this veneer of
balance right and I think John made it
his point to not have that he never said
he was fair and balanced but he did so
much more to the truth and andrew Lee
honest he's super honest and I think we
learned a lot because of that I really
loved how he was able to like listen to
a politician of somebody talk and say
you know what you said XYZ but in
nineteen some odd you said right
completely your friends he used the
hypocritical politician right what they
said five years ago what they said today
put them side by side and I remember
watching that as a journalist in college
and they're in the mid-2000s and going
why doesn't every anchor do that and
then John could add sketches and
hyperbole and jokes and go into a way
that other journalists because they're
trying to be balanced they're trying to
not lose contact to their source they
couldn't do and I wasn't just John doing
it like this might be making me come
across a little nerdy but I was a really
big fan of the view in college all the
women talking sure because again they're
not saying they're journalists it was
Whoopi Goldberg Joy Behar oh yeah Rosie
but they were able to question the
politicians like mccain and obama and
clinton in a way that that other
journals just don't do because they
don't want to be like oh I don't want
people to think we're biased what do you
think some of his shortcomings where I
think towards the end Jon Stewart was
harping on the media a lot on Fox I me
like we get it Fox News is this way we
get it John he's going on the top right
now right right and I think he's so it's
time for him to go I get it John Oliver
then when he came on with last week
tonight on HBO his show now is a lot
more explaining the issues in a way
I think Jon used to Jon Stewart used to
do and so now John Oliver is doing it's
sort of taking over and I'm really into
that show he talks for like 17 minutes
on the most boring topic but I'm
interested thanks so much for joining
absolutely no doubt all right thank you
guys for watching keep it like to aj+
for more news videos and stories we're
in all your social media feeds so
finance their piece
you